you know that Luck's not real right is
luck not real yeah tell me so luck is
purely a psychological concept so all
these people who are like oh I got lucky
no you didn't it's probability
probability is a mathematical concept
meaning that the hand that you get dealt
you had lower high probability of
getting that hand same thing with
outcomes in life yeah right it's all
probability based yep luck is a
psychological concept meaning that let's
say you and I both go to war right your
leg gets blown off yep and I say to you
man you know what you were really
unlucky that you're the one who was
sitting in that seat in that vehicle
that got blown up and you may say back
to me no I'm lucky because I got my
other two arms and legs it's all the
mentality I completely agree with you
but don't you think that viewing
yourself as a lucky individual will give
you an advantage as viewing yourself as
an unlike individual even though it's
all probability based if you go through
like there's an academic research that
suggests literally the best way to
become quote-unquote more lucky is to
literally just start saying I'm a lucky
person I actually completely agree with
you